Степан Бандера казав ми перемагаємо тоді
коли перемагають наші ідеї
фундаментальна позиція європейської
солідарності все для збройних сил
України всі 10 років цієї війни тому
сьогодні для нас Важливо щоб сесійна
зала нарешті почула це відмовилася від
всього другорядного і всі кошти
спрямували на підтримку Збройних Сил
України дійсно важливо що комісія ця
робоча група створена і працює
конструктивно і в законопроекті який ми
сьогодні розглядаємо є чотири ключових
блоки перший - це виплати дійсно ми
збільшимо виплати курсантам ми
збільшуємо виплати строковикам ми даємо
відповідь щодо поранених і МИ повертаємо
30 000 а виплат коли колега говорять що
тут немає тарифної сітки Так це дійсно
завдання уряду розробляти тарифну сітку
і це уряд Вибачте не забирав вже це
фінансування тому насправді
уряд має просто повернути те що було не
у Верховною Радою України ліквідовано
перше друге дуже важливо ми маємо
інвестувати В нашого воїна не тільки
фінанси ми маємо його навчити і озброїти
для того щоби зменшити кількість
загиблих і поранених і в цьому
законопроекті закладена ідея ініціатива
в європейської солідарності щодо
обов'язкових тренінгів обов'язкових
навчань перед відправкою на фронт
особливо коли це мова іде про сили
тероборони ми маємо виправити нашу
спільну помилку Коли прийняли закон про
террооборону а не не дали відповіді як
навчити воїна і це тут закладається і ми
Закликаємо тому прийняти цей
законопроект в першому і другому читанні
третє дуже важливе дійсно відпустка тому
що солдати сьогодні вони є виснаженими і
мають право відпочити і ключове цей
законопроект дає відповідь на те як
сьогодні повернути виплати тому дуже
важливо щоб ми проголосували за основу і
в цілому Коли говорять в залі що у нас
недостатньо сьогодні врахована позиція
по інструкторам - це так і тому робоча
група буде продовжувати працювати
Вибачте в нас взагалі треба повернути
годину запитань до уряду для того щоб
щоразу тут сидів міністр оборони міністр
ветеранів у нас країна ветеранів
сьогодні А ветеранської політики не
існує і постійно ми діалозі з
парламентом давали відповідь на ці
питання і вибачте коли питають А де
взяти гроші так європейська Солідарність
неодноразово давала відповідь де взяти
гроші забрати їх з марафону забрати з
усіх корупційних статей починаючи від
так званого дорожнього будівництва які
ми бачимо з якими корупцією
продовжується в час повномасштабного
вторгнення і закінчується вашими ж
обіцянками що відгорного бізнесу в нас
будуть мільярди мільярди де вони що від
е-е у нас буде від митниці мілья рди де
вони припиніть цю контрабанду Яка й досі
триває І власне